the idea of someone fluffing up their
resume with made-up stuff might sound
like something straight out of a sitcom
I have the same thing I'm a doctor too
but there have been plenty of actors who
have been caught red-handed using
made-up achievements to get onto the red
carpet here are just a few actors who
have lied to get the part
Laura Fraser when the producers of AMC's
hit series Breaking Bad asked actress
Laura Fraser and I apologize to any
Germans watching this sprits 2 died she
answered with an unequivocal yeah the
truth was though that Fraser had barely
any experience with German unlike her
character the conniving anxious TV a
loving Lydia rodarte-quayle she didn't
regret the decision but she did have to
eat her own words later when she was
handed a full paragraph of German
dialogue and had to wing it
this is he owns a girl ugly Fraser told
the Daily Mail it was corporate speak
German and it was a nightmare it took me
days to learn a little paragraph the
benefit apart from the fact that she got
the role of course now I bought my
family with it is my party trick eddie
redmayne now that he's an Oscar winner
any Redmayne probably doesn't have to
use a phony bio to get his role of
choice but once upon a time he was an
up-and-comer who would say and do
anything to score a key part when he
went south for the British TV series
Elizabeth the first Redmayne claimed to
be able to ride a horse when well he
couldn't
after casually lying to director Tom
Hooper and being given a scene on
horseback two weeks later the truth came
out as he remembered to Vanity Fair I
gave my horse a nudging it went off at a
hundred miles an hour I was sent to
horse camp immediately Hooper must not
have minded the deception though because
he also hired red mane for his big
screen adaptation of lay miss Arab and
his 2015 film the Danish girl Hooper may
have gone a little payback though by
having read Maine jump on horseback with
a flag Joel Amos said read me that was
my penance my payback for that light to
him years ago carla Gugino when she was
16 carla Gugino nabbed her first film
role in troop Beverly Hills by claiming
that she was just 14
she didn't confess until later in the
shoot when her role was already safe she
recounted the event to talk show host
James Corden I told the director like
three weeks in once I knew I couldn't
get fired cuz we'd shot another I was
like gesina I am sixteen I thought for
sure he was gonna be like oh no big deal
seems like huh I would have never hired
you about your 16 with that Gugino
learned her lesson about lying and vowed
she's never done it again Whoopi
Goldberg
born Karen Elaine Johnson Whoopi
Goldberg stage name is just part of the
image adjustment that went into given
the award winner has started
entertainments early on in her
illustrious career she had to fake being
older in order to NAB worthy roles
because she was seen as too young for
showbiz on her resume she switched her
year of birth from 1955 to 1949 later
explaining to the Daily News I lied
about my age for a long time because
nobody would hire me to act everyone
said I was too young so when I was 20 I
put six years of my life unfortunately
starring in Theodore Rex put another 10
years on Whoopi's life as well George
Lazenby Australian model George Lazenby
had almost no screen experience when he
convinced producers that he was
qualified to step into Sean Connery's
swanky shoes as James Bond my name is
bond
James Bond the new bomb equipped with a
false bio and a whole lot of bravado
Lazenby made it all the way to an
audition for the role in front of
director Peter hunt when he finally came
clean about his false credentials the
bold move impressed hunts so much say he
was willing to overlook the truth
Lazenby told the New York Post Hunt
swore him to secrecy saying what and you
say you can't act you fooled two of the
most ruthless men I've ever met in my
life
stick to your story and I'll make you
the next James Bond Lazenby starred in
on Her Majesty's Secret Service and was
even contracted for many more Bond films
but he bailed out due to creative
differences returning the role to Sean
Connery why my name is bond James Barr
Lazenby Connery doesn't matter because
we can all agree that Daniel Craig is
the best right guys right
I like that James Bond is ugly now I
liked it he doesn't have any gadgets I
like that he's not good at shooting
doesn't say funny quips or do any James
Bond stuff just killing Timothy Dalton
all the way thanks for watching if
you're looking for another channel
exploring cold topics and unusual and
super entertaining ways then go check
out Niki Swift Niki Swift is your
one-stop shop for all things celebrity
keeping you up to speed on the latest
scandals breakup secrets and more from
Hollywood Niki Swift released his
addictive new videos every day
click here to visit their channel page
and subscribe with lying on the mind go
check out their video about stars who
got caught lying about their age so go
subscribe to Niki Swift and tell them
looper sent you